ABOUT COVID IN THE RED VERSUS
BLUE STATES.
BUT FIRST, JOE BIDEN’S
ANNOUNCEMENT OF KAMALA HARRIS AS
VP, WELL, IT CONTAINS A TELLING
TIDBIT.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID IN THE
WRITTEN STATEMENT, "I DECIDED
KAMALA HARRIS IS THE BEST PERSON
TO HELP ME TAKE THIS FIGHT TO
DONALD TRUMP AND MIKE PENCE, AND
THEN TO LEAD THIS NATION
STARTING IN JANUARY 2021."
WAIT, WAIT, TO LEAD THIS NATION?
WASN’T THAT YOU, SUPPOSED TO BE
ON THE TOP OF THE TICKET DOING
ALL THAT MEETING FOR US, JOE?
YOU KNOW, THAT WHOLE PRESIDENCY
THEN?
COME ON, MAN.
JOE EVEN UNDERSTANDS THAT HE’S
NOT GOING TO BE RUNNING THE SHOW
IF HE WINS IN NOVEMBER.
>> IT HAS TO BE DEMONSTRATED
THAT WHOMEVER I PICK IS TWO
THINGS: ONE, IS CAPABLE OF BEING
PRESIDENT, BECAUSE I AM AN OLD
GUY, OKAY?
[LAUGHTER]
NO, BUT I’M SERIOUS.
>> Laura: WELL, NOW THAT WE
KNOW WHO WILL REALLY BE TAKING
THE REINS AND A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, LET’S TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT SHE’LL DO IF THEY
ARE ELECTED.
TODAY, "THE NEW YORK TIMES" WENT
TO THE ABSURD ROUTE OF TOUTING A
SENATOR AS A "MODERATE," OF
COURSE, THE OPPOSITE IS THE CASE
CASE.
FOR STARTERS, HER POSITION ON
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS.
>> I BELIEVE IF SOMEONE CROSSES
OVER THE BORDER ILLEGALLY, IT IS
ILLEGAL, HE WOULD DECRIMINALIZE
IT.
>> I WOULD NOT MAKE IT A CRIME
PUNISHABLE BY JAIL.
>> Laura: OF COURSE NOT!
COME ON IN!
AND WHAT ABOUT TAXPAYER-FUNDED
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL THOSE NEW
UNDOCUMENTED DEMOCRATS?
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR
GOVERNMENT PLAN WOULD PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: DON’T YOU LOVE THE
HAND RAISE QUESTIONS?
DON’T YOU LOVE THOSE?
WHAT ABOUT ABORTION?
>> WE ARE GOING TO PUT IN PLACE
AND REQUIRE THAT STATES THAT
HAVE A HISTORY OF PASSING
LEGISLATION THAT IS DESIGNED TO
PREVENT OR LIMIT A WOMAN’S
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE, THAT THOSE LAWS
HAVE TO COME BEFORE MY
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR A
REVIEW.
>> Laura: THAT’S CALLED
PRECLEARANCE.
THAT MEANS PARTIAL BIRTH
ABORTION EDITIONS, UNDER
PRESIDENT HARRIS.
AND SHE LOVES SOCIALIZED
MEDICINE.
>> YOU THINK LIMITING PRIVATE
INSURANCE WOULD BE A SOCIALIST
IDEA?
>> NO, OKAY, SO MY -- I STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT A SOCIALIST
OR NOT, MEDICARE FOR ALL?
>> NO, IT IS ABOUT PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE TO ALL PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THAT WORKED OUT WELL
FOR CALIFORNIA, WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING OUT THERE.
AND DID I MENTION THAT KAMALA
ALSO WANTS TO TAKE YOUR GUNS
AWAY?
>> UPON BEING ELECTED, I WILL
GIVE THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
100 DAYS TO GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER AND HAVE THE COURAGE TO
PASS REASONABLE GUN SAFETY LAWS,
AND IF THEY FAIL TO DO IT, THAT
I WILL TAKE EXECUTIVE ACTION.
>> Laura: REASONABLE GUN
SAFETY, A LITTLE -- HERE COME
THE GUNS.
THE TIMES ALSO CALLED HER
PRAGMATIC.
WE SAY THAT’S FRAUDULENT.
TULSI GABBARD EXPOSED KAMALA AS
A PHONY ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
>> SENATOR HARRIS SAYS SHE’S
PROUD OF HER RECORD AS A
PROSECUTOR AND SHE’LL BE A
PROSECUTOR PRESIDENT.
SHE PUT OVER 1500 PEOPLE IN JAIL
FOR MARIJUANA CHARGES.
>> I AM PROUD OF MAKING A
DECISION TO NOT JUST MAKE FANCY
SPEECHES OR BE IN A LEGISLATIVE
BODY AND GIVE SPEECHES ON THE
FLOOR.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED UNDER
YOUR REIGN AS PROSECUTOR, YOU
OWE THEM AN APOLOGY.
>> Laura: TULSI GABBARD JUST
TOOK HER APART, DO YOU REMEMBER
THAT DEBATE?
FURTHERMORE, SENATOR HARRIS
BASICALLY ACCUSED JOE BIDEN OF
BEING A RACIST ON NATIONAL TV.
>> THAT’S HURTFUL, TO HEAR YOU
TALK ABOUT THE REPUTATION OF TWO
UNITED STATES SENATORS WHO BUILT
THEIR REPUTATIONS AND CAREER ON
THE SEGREGATION OF RACE.
YOU ALSO WORK WITH THEM TO
OPPOSE BUSING, AND YOU KNOW,
THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF A
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, AND SHE WAS
BUSED TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY.
AND THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
>> Laura: THAT WAS THE IT
MOMENT.
WELL, AFTER THAT, SHE VERY
PUBLICLY SUGGESTED BIDEN WAS
GUILTY OF SEXUALLY ASSAULTING
TARA READE.
>> SOMEBODY WHO HAS THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN, WHAT MESSAGE WOULD YOU
GIVE TO THE WOMEN WHO FEEL LIKE
THEIR SPACE HAS BEEN INVADED?
>> I WOULD BELIEVE THEM, AND I
RESPECT THEM BEING ABLE TO TELL
THEIR STORY.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE
VICE PRESIDENT SHOULD ENTER THIS
RACE?
>> HE’S GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
THAT DECISION FOR HIMSELF.
>> Laura: MARINATE AND ALL OF
THAT FOR A MOMENT, OKAY?
PROMOTING ALL OF THESE PAST
SENATORS LIKE ROBERT BYRD’S
FRIENDSHIP, AND IMPLICITLY -- AT
THE VERY LEAST IMPLICIT -- SHE
WAS SAYING HE’S GUILTY OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT, BUT NOW ALL OF A
SUDDEN SHE’S WILLING TO WORK
WITH HIM?
A SEGREGATIONIST AND A CRIMINAL?
IT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
MAY BE SOMEBODY IN THE LAME
STREAM MEDIA WILL HAVE THE
COURAGE TO ASK ABOUT IT.
BUT GIVEN ALL THESE ISSUES, I
HAVE NO DOUBT THAT THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN LOOKED FAR AND WIDE FOR
A BETTER OPTION THAN HARRIS, BUT
I GUESS THERE WASN’T.
WASN’T ANYONE.
SUSAN RICE HAD WAY TOO MUCH
BAGGAGE, AND NO ELECTION
EXPERIENCE.
FORMER OBAMA ADVISOR DAVID
AXELROD SAID TONIGHT BIDEN
ACTUALLY CLICKED BEST WITH
GOVERNOR WHITMER, BUT SHE’S NOT
A WOMAN OF COLOR, AND RUNS
MICHIGAN LIKE A TIN-POT
DICTATORSHIP.
AND THE OTHER CANDIDATES WERE
POLITICAL SMALL FRIES WITHOUT
ANY TYPE OF EXPERIENCE OR NAME
RECOGNITION THAT YOU’D WANT IN A
VP.
OF COURSE, BIDEN’S BIG MISTAKE
OF COURSE WAS NARROWING HIS
OPTIONS BY LIMITING HIS CHOICE
ON THE BASIS OF SKIN COLOR.
AND ON PLANET EARTH, THAT USED
TO BE CALLED BIAS, OR EVEN
RACISM.
UH, USING COLOR AS A METRIC?
WELL, THAT’S WHAT HE DECIDED TO
DO.
AS SOMEONE RUNNING FOR THE
NATION’S HIGHEST OFFICE, BIDEN
IS MORALLY OBLIGATED TO PICK THE
BEST PERSON TO TAKE HIS PLACE IN
THE EVENT OF A TRAGEDY.
REGARDLESS OF RACE OR GENDER OR
ETHNICITY, ANY OF IT.
BUT HE NEVER EVEN TRIED TO DO
THAT.
HOW CYNICAL.
INSTEAD, HE VIEWED THE WHOLE
THING IS A BOX CHECKING EXERCISE
FOR THE WOKE CROWD.
HE SHOULD HAVE MADE HIS CHOICE
JUST ON MERIT, BUT NOW HE IS
STUCK WITH HARRIS, AND THE
BOTTOM LINE, SHE RAN FOR
PRESIDENT NOT SO LONG AGO AND
HAD A GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT HERSELF TO LIBERAL
VOTERS AND THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
BUT THEY REJECTED HER IN THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE MANNER
POSSIBLE, MAKING IT ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR THAT THEY DIDN’T REGARD
HER AS WORTHY OF SERVING AS
PRESIDENT.
NOW, IN A DESPERATE EFFORT TO
PLEASE THE HARD LEFT, BIDEN HAS
REJECTED THE JUDGMENT OF HIS OWN
PARTIES VOTERS AND PLACED HARRIS